>>My name is Mike Useem.
I'm on the faculty at the University of Pennsylvania's
Wharton School,
the business school.
It's been my privilege to participate in the
annual meeting of the
World Economic Forum here in Davos this week.
And my observation about the state of the
world and where we're going
in the next 5 to 10 years is that as expressed
by many people here this
week, the opportunities are large for the
private sector and the public
sector to work actively together.
It's many things of course, including the
willingness on the part of
people in the private sector to take a stint
in government, to take a
public -- active public service role of that
kind.
Or even if not that, for people in the private
sector to become
involved in public service.
Some of the companies who have been active
this week in Davos have also
on their own become active in the recovery
from the catastrophic
developments in Haiti as a form of public
service, obviously.
And the theme that strikes me is maybe one
of the most important issues
at this current World Economic Forum annual
event is that the potential
is enormous for the public sector and the
private sector to work
together to address the big problems that
we face: Education, health
catastrophes of one kind or another.
I think just looking forward the next 5 to
10 years, we're going to see
more public/private partnership.
We are going to see more people moving from
the private sector into the
public sector.
I think we're going to see more people in
the public sector an active
dialogue with people in private industry in
how to solve the problems
that we all face as a global community.
Thank you very much.